this program is brought to you by Emory
University hi I'm Jeff Copeland director
of Emrys Global Health Institute I've
been in public health for over 30 years
most of them that the Centers for
Disease Control across the street from
memory where I was director and for a
long time had responsibility for the
office and smoking and health tobacco
control activities i'm quite familiar
interested in committed to the issues of
tobacco prevention and control i am
delighted that Emery is taking these
steps to make Emery a tobacco-free
campus it's a tough thing to do but it's
an important thing to do when there's a
lot of reasons for that at CDC we made
CDC smoke-free well over 15 years ago
and it was a remarkably smooth
transition and I think everyone has been
favourably pleased with the outcomes of
that the reasons for doing it at Emory
or any major university is itson
consists mocha ng and having tobacco use
on campus is really inconsistent with
the goals and aspirations and values of
a major research university as a
first-rate international institution
Emory needs to set the tone and the pace
and set the bar for what constitutes
good behavior on a university campus
tobacco takes such a major toll of life
and health in this country and around
the world that really is distinct from
any other product even when taken as
used it's harmful even in small doses is
harmful even when others are smoking and
you're exposed to it it's harmful and as
such it really is important and makes
sense to take the steps that Emery is
taking right now what we found and when
people are placed in a smoke-free or
tobacco free environment is a lot of
people who are on the cusp of quitting
quit people who hadn't thought about
before move into that stage where
they're thinking about quitting those
that have been discouraged in the past
when they try to quit now feel that they
have maybe more incentive to do it and
can get more help in quitting so all of
these elements combine to make the
environment a healthier place for people
to work and live in and visit tobacco
control is a extremely important element
of public health practice and Emory it
with its nursing school public health
school in medical school and multiple
hospitals and clinics needs to really
set the tone on the bar for how we
approach health promoting behavior and
tobacco is a very important part of that
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University